[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is an
incredible wonderful hilarious
interesting and fun chat with my new
friend Chris Estrada who is one of the
creators and the star of one of my new
favorite shows it's called this fool
it's on Hulu we talk about it on this
episode right here on this couch it's so
hard to find new shows it's hard it's so
hard to find great new shows and I
really think he's doing something very
special one of the EPS is Fred Armisen
and Chris kills it it's so funny it's so
unique definitely definitely definitely
check out this fool and follow Chris on
all his socials and what you and what
where you follow your people
uh I am currently on tour if you want to
come see me the remaining cities are San
Francisco Portland Seattle Atlanta
Charlotte
and Washington D.C we're hopefully going
to be adding new dates as well in the
new year but if you want to come and see
me do my new hour of stand up I'm really
proud of it it's been really really
great so far and it means so much that
weirdos come out just go to
petehomes.com and you will see links to
all of the tickets there and if you like
this podcast why not try a pizza pick
like our friends at ritual when I travel
speaking of being on the road there's
only two vitamins two bottles of pills I
take a lot of different things some for
sleep some for this but the only ones
that I absolutely always always take
with me are my ritual multivitamin and
my ritual symbiotic plus symbiotic plus
is my pre uh Pro and post biotic what
does that mean it means it's all of my
gut health in one easy to take delayed
release pill which means it delays
release which Waits until it's in your
lower intestine which is where it needs
to be to actually be effective uh
probiotic which means gut health your
gut is basically like a second brain and
keeping it healthy is super super
important for virtually every area of
your life not to mention my ritual
multivitamin as a mostly vegan person
I'm deficient in a lot of vitamins that
used to be in our soil they used to be
in our food and now taking my ritual
multivitamin when I go to the doctor I
get no notes no notes and I can take it
on an empty stomach which is huge
because if you I don't know if you've
ever taken something like zinc on an
empty stomach it will make you vomit but
ritual has a delayed release and a minty
taste so it gets into your system and
breaks down in the lower parts into the
lower intestine where you can actually
absorb this stuff but putting a
highlight on symbiotic plus the pro
pre-post biotic contains two of the
world's most studied strains uh with
over 350 publications of human clinical
trials it is a three-in-one clinically
studied as I mentioned Prebiotic
probiotic and post-biotic to support a
balanced gut microbiome it doesn't need
to be refrigerated which is huge as I
mentioned I take it with me when I
travel it's a single nested minty
capsule which means it leaves a nice
minty aftertaste in your mouth and it is
designed to thrive as I mentioned
delayed release so it will break down in
your colon not the stomach which is the
ideal place for your probiot biotics to
survive and grow so show your body some
love show your gut some support and show
your support of this podcast symbiotic
plus and ritual are here to celebrate
not hide your insides there's no more
shame in your gut game to try making
something new easier ritual is offering
weirdos 10 off their first three months
when you shop online at ritual.com weird
or if you prefer to shop in person
ritual is now available at Whole Foods
Market but why not use the promo code
and show that these ads are working
that's how we keep the lights on Go to
ritual.com weird do your body a favor
and show your support of this show
speaking of products that I love and
have changed my life living Libations
you guys have heard us talk about living
libations for many years our whole
household is a living Libations family
what does that mean it's skin care it's
hair care it's it's Oral Care everything
that you put on or in your body body for
beauty reasons for health reasons to
look good to feel good living Libations
has got you covered years ago I realized
I was being very careful about what I
ate and what I put inside but I wasn't
being very careful about what I put on
my body when it comes to things like
moisturizers or shaving creams or even
dental care a lot of these things are
filled with chemicals and are linked to
toxicity levels and disease stuff that
is just never intended for human beings
so I was like there's got to be another
way to do this there's got to be skin
care for example where I can read the
ingredients and actually pronounce and
even recognize them because I want my
food to be stuff that I recognize and I
want my skin care to be the same enter
living Libations I now use their zinc
based sunscreen it's called love the sun
we use that for Leela every morning when
we're getting her ready for for
preschool obviously you want to put good
things on your kids skin their love the
sun is the only one that I found that is
actually natural meaning there's a lot
of them that you see online that say
they're natural but they're absolutely
not they're still filled with chemicals
they're just a little bit clever about
it but the living libation Sun uh sun
protection is actually zinc based and
real and natural I use their Ginger
exfoliating scrub which I always say is
not only natural and has ingredients I
recognize but it's the most badass
exfoliant I've ever used in my life I
use their Zen shave both Val and I use
their best skin ever moisturizer before
bed smells great feels great going on
and keeps your skin looking vibrant and
Alive because it's made with ingredients
that are vibrant and alive but this is a
great company to support the show
because I promise if you want to buy
something little or you want to do a
complete house overhaul like we did it
they have lots of stuff ranging from you
can get a tongue scraper at Living
Libations or you could completely
re-haul your entire Beauty cabinet
living Libations has a premium natural
and wonderful product to replace the
random chemical nightmares that too many
of us are used to so go to living
libations dot com and use promo code
gratitude weird one word capital g
capital D capital W excuse me gratitude
weird capital g capital W and that will
get you your discount that is 15 off
which is pretty great and show your
support of this podcast uh just go to
livinglibations.com promo code gratitude
weird alright everybody enjoy Chris
Estrada it's such a great conversation
and be sure to check out this fool on
Hulu get into it
is water hey you haven't seen that
before no
learned about you from watching the show
and watching your stand up I'm like
we'll just roll right in if you could oh
no no open open open I just want you to
know we're recording so you don't start
saying some racist [__]
and also feel free to put that stand by
my racism I say it on anything that was
caught in private please keep it in the
show as a point of integrity and you can
put your feet on the couch it's a filthy
couch yeah yeah but I really do think we
get go get comfy I'm gonna insist at
least lean in yeah have some have some
pillows there you go
it's uh this couch isn't exactly right
oh it's nice it's a nice cozy ass couch
it truly is you're very positive already
and I'm already enjoying it I'm not a
like I'm not high maintenance yeah
that's great yeah I'm gonna put this
back because I was enjoying it
um but yeah I was just first of all the
show is fantastic oh thank you I really
appreciate you taking the time to watch
it dude it's great yeah it was like yes
I watch it for the show but I watch it
with my wife and and she doesn't love
everything I don't love everything yeah
and we were both like that was so good
we're like thanks now we're just
watching it because it's what we're
watching yeah and I know that
everybody's making this point but it's
so hard to find like what to watch yeah
yeah and I'm glad to have this podcast
because you know we were having you on
so I was like oh we should watch this
fool yeah we put her on and I was like
first of all it's just so hard to do
can you relate like I watch a lot of TV
and I'm like
why like why does this I'm not even in a
mean way you almost feel bad for them
you're like yeah there's no point of
view yeah there's no point of view or
thematically I go I guess I like themes
in television you know I don't like
things that feel like a morale morality
play but I like things that are thematic
you do these mess with themes so or
sometimes you have things like a point
of view I'm like
you know it when things like a point of
view what I like to I don't want that
from scripted television I don't mind
that like I love Bar Rescue it's like
trash like trashy TV that I don't mind
but at least that dude has a theme which
has uh has a point of view which is
don't have a shitty bar don't have a
shitty bar all you need is the title
he's going to rescue he's gonna rescue
your bar goes in and those shows are a
delight because we all have strong
opinions about dumb stuff yeah yeah he
like gets away
John Taffer John Taffer I always say uh
he's the father I didn't have because
you know like you need a grown man to
yell at you sometimes dude you're on the
right podcast I think all of that stuff
uh Gordon what's his name the mean one
the British Ramsay Gordon Ramsay yeah
that's all dad's stuff it's all dead
Simon on American Idol yeah you know why
because they show up Social fantasy yeah
they're mad but they're like they
understand like why do you have this
kitchen like this we kind of wished yeah
I would watch it look I don't mean to
put my dad down he did he did a great
job and I love him but there was like uh
growing up in the 80s like 80s dads
didn't really have that yeah that
understanding or or or even the goal of
being like involved yeah to that extent
where they might come in my room and be
like I feel like your Ninja Turtles are
getting mixed up with your GI Joe's like
let's get those separated so you can
have a more efficient play time I would
be like yes sir
loved any attention yeah my pops wasn't
around so sometimes I things seeing
stuff like that is like where I it must
be to something in me where I just go
like because I I think of my nephews and
they have their dad around but whenever
I'm kind of like Stern with them yeah
I've seen them smile or be like yes okay
they're boys yeah yeah they're boys and
the girls don't like it but I've seen in
particular this is just my experience
little boys will love yeah they will
love that like I kind of Boss them
around not in a mean way but like no no
eat all your food first before we do
this and you'll be like smile okay and
then you know so because it's care yeah
it's care it's also structure yeah we
always talk about with our daughter it's
like you like she has toys and stuff
that count to ten it's like one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve I just wanted to say yeah
and I was like it would be like if you
went into some weird DMT universe and
everybody's a ribbon right there's just
a bunch of ribbons and everything just
looks like tie-dye and everything's
moving around it's all chaos but they
give you a toy and it's like Frank
Stars you'd take such Comfort yeah like
look everything's nuts but Frank's name
think they get the same way when you're
like no you're here in this Dimension we
eat our food first yes that's what I
like about that kind of television or
seeing like Bar Rescue I used to say
that that show is an analogy for loser
dudes
the bar is the dude you're so right
because in that thing they always tell
them like okay you have a cut like dress
up but like it's it's all like physical
like okay this place looks like it needs
it smells bad yes let's hide the kitchen
you have a female population about two
miles away that you're not catering to
like
that's great it just kills me it's all
advice you would give a guy yeah it's
all those bars are yeah it's queer eye
but for a restaurant yes yeah yeah but
it's it's intense Direct Care yeah and
somebody taking the time I always worry
though that like did you ever watch the
prophet no it's it's a sort of a bar
rescue I don't want to say rip off but
like they're all sort of derivative of
each other but this guy goes in and gets
companies to like clean up their act not
just business not just a restaurant but
all types of businesses yeah but you
always get the feeling and I want to
know if you feel the same way as soon as
these people leave this thing's going
straight to hell yes yeah
I always look up too like on Bar Rescue
you can see you look out yeah
and then some of them a lot of them fail
like a lot of them they go back to their
old ways I would absolutely and those
people that have the ideas for shows to
help bars are just sort of it's not mean
exploiting no because they are they are
trying to help they're trying yeah yeah
they know yeah it would be like if you
and I were like let's do it like
American Idol is that in a big way it's
like let's get people that can't sing
but we'll put it do it like we're gonna
make your dreams come true yeah but they
know really people would like to watch
someone burn and yeah I think a lot of
these bars like I mean usually like for
most of them they always say they like
did well after but I look to see like
where are they now after three to four
years
yeah a lot some of them like a fair
amount that I see are closed yeah like
or for reasons that they went back to
their old ways or whatever because yeah
a therapist in there to be like do you
want to be in the restaurant business
that or business school you know like my
business school yeah but I hear you
business school would help but I think
like if there's like it's like there's a
projector right and it's trying to play
a movie of owning a bar and they can you
can clean the screen as much as you want
but if you don't take that piece of [__]
off the lens right I know we've all
heard that analogy but I think they do
need to go in and go like do you like
service yeah yeah do you like food
service yeah I think does somebody light
you up at all I think the places that
run well are like people who like like
that are like there's places that I've
looked up that are still running yeah
and I I always got the feeling that
those people just got like hit with hard
times or some [__] happened yes like or
you could tell they they like it they
like being in the service industry like
there was this guy who ran this place in
Vegas it was like an old school mob
joint okay and then like even the Rat
Pack would go there and I don't know he
just he seemed like he liked it it just
he was like hitting hard times and that
place is still around he's doing great
yeah yeah because I think I had this
theory that a lot of people a lot the
reason why a lot of teachers suck is
because that's the job choice of people
who don't know what to do yeah they're
not even putting it down no no no I
don't think I'm making fun I'm just
saying a lot of people strike out I get
it I actually feel for them what do you
do and you go like well who have I seen
you've probably seen some teachers yeah
second tier down what do you do I go out
to restaurants you know like waiters
yeah and then like bar but like it's not
just you like being in bars or you have
the fantasy of like you talk to the
customers you go to the bar they give
you a shot of something yeah it's not
that it's not Romanticism no you
actually have to like
enjoy the thought that other people had
a great time yeah yeah to be a chef or a
restaurant like it's those people who
love being bartenders when they like at
a busy bar they're like nah this [__]
it's fast it's moving yes like it's not
this cheers fantasy right you know it's
like slow yeah where it's slow and
you're chopping it up with everyone
they're like no no we want to [__]
they want to feel like rock stars where
they're moving fast that's right yeah
spinning a bottle every once in a while
every once in a while not every bottle
not every bottle yeah
that's so funny man I went to bartending
school oh did you yeah because I know we
scandalized but Bill Cosby was a
bartender and he was a hero of mine and
I was like what how do you become a
comedian yeah and I think in those days
it was the 50s yeah that like was open
miking it yeah I mean there were no Open
Mic so you had to be a funny bartender I
like Colin Quinn a lot he used to be a
bartender oh really yeah you can tell
yeah yes you could tell yeah he kind of
has that old Barb like he could make my
dad laugh and he could make me laugh
yeah yeah that's incredibly yeah I love
that bit you had about you didn't call
it Warehouse funny but if I was tracking
your seat you know what's so funny it's
called Warehouse funnies I literally
it's called Warehouse funny yeah
it's called The Warehouse funny that's
exactly what it's called Warehouse funny
yeah because I was a waiter at
Bennigan's 150 South Michigan yeah in
Chicago it's gone it's a Walgreens now
but um I was a waiter there and I
related to your bit Yeah so hard oh I
think that there's like different yeah
there's just different levels of being
funny like sometimes being that funny at
work doesn't translate to like being
funny anymore I say yeah always always
yeah you're right
never it's a completely yeah Robert
Klein had this great line which was
Haunting to me in my early years but he
was like there's a big difference
between being funny and being funny at
eight o'clock on a Friday night at a
comical you're showing up to be funny
it's a job it's a yes yeah it's like a
craft at that point it's a craft and
it's a huge disappointment if all the
people paid like 35 50 bucks each and
you suck I know like very different from
like you're hungover at work and you're
just not funny that day no problem no
problem yeah
I know I wish I was like telling someone
it's like
what sucks is about like with certain
jobs you can be depressed and do it fine
yes but like I we were talking about I
was like telling my friend about flying
and like what worries me as those Pilots
that like killed themselves you know
like that Malaysian air flight that went
missing that that was a few years ago
there was a Malaysian airplane there's a
strong speculation that that guy killed
himself and that he was depressed and
then I go you just don't want a
depressed pilot look I don't I don't
like putting this bad stuff out there
but I've had that thought in New York in
a cab being like first of all I don't
think this guy even remembers that I'm
in here yeah I don't mean an Uber I mean
a cap yeah of course yeah straight up he
might just be driving around yeah New
York right now yeah and we're going over
Bridges and stuff and I'm just like like
trying to talk talk yeah give that guy
some hope or something a little chatter
yeah yeah tell him you got a great back
ahead I love this bag of hair but it's
true like the the interconnected
goodness of humanity but that doesn't
just end with like flights flights is a
really obvious example but your dentist
your doctor those are those are going to
come the people who serve your food I
know the amount of trust is insane and
you're in a warehouse shipping things
out yeah you'd have to go out of your
way to like put Anthrax or something of
course yeah it's a human-packed a box is
that the kind of Warehouse it was yeah I
worked at a Car Parts Warehouse so it
was like and I worked at several
warehouses throughout my life but it was
just like it just would make me laugh
because when I was out of where anytime
I worked any job like I would especially
at a warehouse job I would I would crack
myself up because I thought I was like
God I [__] hate this job yes so I
would always go up to one of my
co-workers and jokingly I would say hey
don't tell anyone but I'm with
Undercover Boss
[Laughter]
like just kind of [__] with them and
they would laugh and think I was an
idiot and like but it's just one of
those things that like it would never
work anywhere one percent of them is
like is Chris yeah is Chris like I
believe he was an Undercover Boss you
joke about that on the show that you
like look older than you are yeah so
there's something like I could see you
as a CEO yeah I hope so yeah for sure
but it's like just kind of pretending to
be in the warehouse yeah but yeah
there's just something to being it's so
funny how
certain funnies only work in a specific
Place well that's what not to be I'm
catching myself not to be hurt about
this but I did notice in my family when
they would come and see me do stand-up
or whatever it was confusing to them
because first of all it wasn't about
them I'm just kind of like talking about
my thoughts and I think they wanted it
to be more Warehouse funny yeah they
wanted me to like engage in fact that's
what bad audiences often are it's like
why isn't he talking about me yes yeah
you should like do snaps on me man I
didn't come here to do snaps on the
front right yeah that's what happened to
me one time I was at Acme in Minneapolis
I hear that and then it's an amazing
Club yeah but somebody up front said
roast me and then I said what the [__]
you think I'm Jeff Ross right like I
mean that's a skill it's a great skill
yes and I think and I enjoy watching it
but it's not what I do I had that at the
lab here in L.A yeah where there was a
dude in the front who of course I found
out like five minutes after talking to
him that he was also a comic and I'm
like what do you like I just noticed
everyone was clapping when I came up I
wasn't even announced it wasn't like a a
big deal that I was there I was just one
of the comics on the lineup and he was
like this yeah and I was like I just I
addressed it to him because I wanted to
loosen him yeah not to like make fun of
him I was like everybody's clapping but
this guy right in the front row everyone
could see him with his arms crossed and
I was like what's going on and he was
like look at how you're dressed he
started like roasting me really and I
was like
yeah that's not what this is yeah like
it's not 1973 Melrose Empire yeah yeah
we're not all smoking cigarettes yes yes
wearing sunglasses inside yeah long Ash
you need to Ash that thing it's long Ash
about to fall off being like nice pants
they come in your size like get out of
here I know that's not what this is I
hate when I see someone say that to
someone like what do you guys want to
talk about obviously and I go
yeah you talk about something talk about
it you know what it is you're actually
making me realize that what makes comedy
and I do believe it's art I I believe it
can be stupid I believe it can be bass
but it can it's still art even when it's
stupid and even when it's based but one
of the things that makes it art which
sort of makes it corny is that you are
talking about your inner reality yeah
like you're bringing your thoughts and
your feelings and expressing them yeah
so doing roasts I'm not saying Jeff I'm
saying bullshitting with the crowd or
what else do you want to talk about is
kind of a defense because if you try and
if you do talk about your your fears or
your hopes or whatever that's a
vulnerable play You're basically showing
them like a painting of your of your
insides it just that's what I think it's
more interesting to be like I have these
abstract thoughts so let me see how I
can make them funny to a broader
audience yes while still maintaining
some yes uniqueness or abstraction to
them you know well that yeah yeah it's
just yeah I think that's what it is I
mean and also it's like it is in our
form but I also in
I hate being profound about it at the
same time too well it ruins it yeah it
ruins it yeah it's an art form that
requires you to not behold it at too
much of an as an art form to do it yes
you know what I mean I have to imagine a
lot like Landing a plant like yeah
to go back to Pilot don't think about
how amazing it is just landed just land
it nobody cares that you're like really
I'm a mathematician yeah it's really a
game of angles
yeah nobody cares and you can think of
dinar but don't tell every passengers
they're deploying it yeah that's right
only planes get their own verb for
leaving it I know you don't decar okay
okay forget it I love that you laughed
here's a couple things before we get to
some specifics that I loved about the
show but I wanted to talk about I went
on your on your Gram and I noticed
references to adaptation which is one of
my favorite movies I love that movie and
Minor Threat which is yeah I grew up in
punk rock music I'm assuming you don't
still throw on Minor Threat but maybe
you do oh no I still do oh yeah
I don't know why I projected that onto
you so you'll still listen to yeah out
of Step yeah I still listen all that
stuff I think I think um
at one time the singer of minor thread
and fugazi the Skye and Makai he said
this thing that I thought was really
profound which she said I didn't grow
out of I didn't grow out of punk rock I
grew up with it so that's how you feel
that's how I feel I feel like it still
resonates like that kind of anger or
like it's interesting yeah like all that
stuff still resonates to me and I grew
up listening to it here in LA and it
felt like such a I think it shaped me to
who I am so I still I think I listen to
more things you know like but I still
listen to that there was no judgment
here oh yeah I thought maybe you threw
it into gear being like look I like
other stuff the anthrax house is right
around the corner oh really yeah it's
not the Minor Threat house where they're
standing on the steps and there's the
glendanzic houses around oh that's what
it is
which is like this weird abandoned house
yeah we all know belongs to Danza and he
does nothing with that and it's really
just kind of falling apart which is kind
of punk rock yeah that's good for yeah
very Misfits yeah it's very Misfits
indeed but I I loved Minor Threat were
you straight edge
you know I wasn't I man I started
everything really young like I was never
doing yeah like I smoked weed when I was
10 for the first time yeah with my
neighbor
my neighbor's Uncle used to sell weed
and then we smoked and one time his
uncle left and then he came over and we
smoked weed together at like 10 or 11.
how old was he he was the same age who
was like 10 or 11 and then he came over
I'm sorry I thought you meant it was 10
or 11 at night oh no no no I was like
first of all that's too late to be up at
10. but you were 10 or 11 and you smoked
10 or 11 smoked weed did you get high
they say you don't get it you know
what's so funny is I think when I was a
kid I just I just remember going I knew
I was high but I didn't feel it but in
hindsight I knew we were high because we
went to the store to buy a bunch of
Munchies you got the munchies yeah we
got the munchies I've told the story
before but I I uh got my friend stoned
for the first time and he got paranoid
that he wasn't stoned which is the
funniest way to be stoned he's like it's
not working he's not working I was like
see this I was also stoned but I was
like see the way you're being yeah this
is stoned like this is it yeah and he
finally it's weird that it requires like
a yes from you or some sort of surrender
or participation into surrender
surrender yeah to be high well yeah to
be high well yeah or resistant yeah and
you're and then you have these terrible
yeah when you're fighting it and you're
fine you don't even think it's happening
and it's like the reason why the cliche
is like The Big Lebowski it's like get
in the bathtub and get a roach put like
[__] relax yeah so you smoked at 10
did that have like an effect on you I
don't mean to sound so square but I was
28. you know I grew up here in LA and so
like that kind of like drug culture was
around people selling me like people
flying in dope and like selling drugs
you knew to be around you would see
people sell drugs so it wasn't a big
deal it wasn't like a big deal and you
also I had smelled it before like in the
neighborhood and stuff but it was my
friend came over and he was like my
uncle left he had a joint like a rolled
up joint or like yeah let's smoke it and
you know I think I smoked after that
for like recreationally once I got into
high school with friends and stuff like
so after 10 you waited till like I think
yeah yeah I remember I was like never
smoking again until like high school and
then I drank beer I think I got drunk
the first time when I was like 12 like
12 or 13. oh wow and then what was that
situation same kid no my other friend my
other friend his brother bought us a 12
pack his brother was older and I think
we just said like we want to get [__]
up and his brother was like all right
I'm gonna buy you guys a 12 pack get
drunk at like at home at home did was
that what he's saying yeah yeah like do
it safe yeah yep and we ended up buying
a 12-pack he got us a 12 pack we ended
up getting drunk and but I didn't drink
again until like high school and smoke
weed twice and I never had a problem but
I just wasn't straight edge but what I
did is I respected it yeah like I used
the substances no I respected the
factory straight edge yeah you know or
the fact that like people is almost a
discipline I wish I had even though I
wasn't like necessary there yeah like
the fact that they were just like I'm
not gonna let this ruin my life yes you
know I related hard to that yeah because
they made it cool to quote Huey Lewis
they made it hip to be square you know I
wasn't doing that stuff for religious
reasons yeah but then I'm in the punk in
the hardcore scene yeah and I got to say
I was straight edge and everybody just
thought it was like a cool kind of
because it is I know I'm a 43 year old
lamo dad now but I'm like if you're into
punk rock and you're sober like that
dude's dangerous
what's up with him like he wants dimash
and all he's had today is a cup of tea
or it also feels like too like it also I
heard maybe it was like Henry Rollins or
in Makai who said like they want you to
become a cliche
so you're not functional yeah you know
yeah and they want you to be
self-destructive yeah you know this kind
of authoritarian rule or whatever that
like abstract they is yeah like so
you're not mobilizing or doing things to
change your life for the better that's
right or so you're not to keep you down
yeah or to you know
be a consumer and stuff like that so
that kind of idea I really like like I
always thought even sometimes when I I
feel like sometimes even when I want to
buy like junk food like a bottle of Coke
or something yeah I have to tell myself
that
I have to make it an enemy always how
you don't do it yeah it's how I don't do
it by making it an enemy I think that's
brilliant yeah because who is telling
you that it's freedom in fact like coke
coke is always my go-to example that
yeah the advertisement is always like
partying on a beach or like having the
best time of your life with the most
beautiful person you've ever met it's
like bubble sugar water like yeah and we
know that yeah but we're so susceptible
to images but like that one step of
removal to say like who told you that
getting [__] up was like what Kings do
yes that's how kings do no it's not what
Kings do actually Kings because they
didn't get [__] up or exactly they're
quite lame I'm sure I mean I'm sure some
of those inbred weirdos in Europe were
just like inherited like with an eye and
we went this far over like they drank a
lot of Ale and Mead and [__] but like
a lot of the people that you tend to
admire that's why I always get bummed
out when you see Michael Jordan not
really bummed out but like Michael
Jordan doing McDonald's commercials and
you're like I get it nobody first of all
I don't know man I can't judge but like
you don't eat that stuff like you don't
like and it's kind of we've sort of
gotten a little bit wiser to that idea
yeah even like the milk yeah I thought
sometimes I want to have like soda or
junk food and I have to tell myself no
they want you to buy it blindly that's
what they want destroy and then that
helps me because then I if I make it an
enemy in that sense well what makes it
an enemy is anything that's a
corporation that wants you to get hooked
on their product it is a drug and and
sugar or uh other addictive things
there's no yeah why is one thing a
dragon one is I I know this is like you
know
who needs to hear me talk about this
stuff again no but but you did bring it
up no I talked about this stuff a lot
but that's what I that's what I love
about that even though and even to this
day I I couldn't I like to have a drink
here and then sure here and there but
like I that's what I like about that
straight edge mentality is yeah like
it's like I'm not gonna lose control
right because then I'm ineffective and
doing it consciously that's yeah I don't
smoke I don't drink I don't [__] it's
funny that sex as well yeah at least I
can [__] think right so that Minor
Threat song was you know the beginning
of being like Oh it's cool to have
discernment or whatever yeah yeah
because like
blindly not doing stuff or blindly doing
stuff both are both are blind yeah and I
know that because I have a
self-destructiveness to me that I would
I and I feel like I have to make things
done to me because I do have like
addictive behavior you know and like I
used to smoke cigarette I used to smoke
like a pack and a half a day and like or
sometimes I would binge things or yeah
at some point I got into I did do like
heavy drugs and and it's because I know
I have us like a self-destructiveness
yeah so if I don't make it and then like
there's a self-loathing part of me that
it's like yeah you're a piece of [__] do
this because you're a piece of [__] but
if I make it then to me then I can go no
don't do that it's a it's a battle it's
not a fix it's yeah it's just somebody
selling you a fake fix yeah so they can
get rich and go on vacation yeah on your
pain yeah which is true what were I I
know you know how I know I'm binging
because it doesn't happen often but like
this is such a lame example but like I
housed pretty much an entire bag of
pistachios which is yeah I sound so dumb
but like you know how I knew and I know
Katie it's so dumb but they were spicy
something that's spicy like you eat it
and then like you get that flare-up of
pain this is addiction yeah and you're
actually chasing that it has nothing to
do no with like your stomach or hunger
you're just trying to like kind of cut
yourself a little bit and that probably
goes into some sort of weird I deserve
pain sort of place but like I know I'm
binging if I say how many pistachios is
enough and I can hear my voice goes
right back and goes never
never enough and then I know I have to
stop I can't always do it but that's
when I'm in that addiction Place yeah I
used to binge in the way with like my uh
I would do drugs with a friend and then
I would go say this whole weekend like
let's party yeah black and white yeah
it's like we're already doing it we're
already doing that we're already gonna
feel bad so let's just do it a time
really bad on Monday yeah that's real I
I I'm just saying I have that too yeah
that's why I had to stop drinking
because I was like if I drink I'm like
well we're doing this yeah so like do it
yes it's actually kind of what made me
good stand up it's what made like at the
lifestyle because I was like we're gonna
do it so we should do it we should do it
every night we should do it in New York
same sort of compulsion but like I had
to get enlightened to the idea that I
was like you need to seek that
never-ending hungry dog on the right
thing yes because if you just let it eat
Doritos I think I'd be dead yeah or that
so or like you know you've
or I'd have the attitude of like yeah
let's get [__] up and
I will deal with it on Monday or we'll
see how far we can take it and who knows
right like it might go into money yeah
am I going to Monday or bad you're not
even
yeah I'll get [__] up I don't even
care what happens yeah and then well
that was also it sorry so yeah it's just
that kind of thought of just like doing
that kind of stuff and then it's like
that kind of addictive behavior and
self-loading that I always have to be
careful with same yeah and I think
that's by the way everybody yeah meaning
I don't think it's like oh addicts have
like something yeah other people are
exercising so they look fantastic but
their addiction is exercising or it's
money it's these things or to work or
it's work yeah things they call our
culture values so like our Strange
compulsions stick out yes because they
look like body weight or they look like
inactivity or hangovers or whatever it
might be but a lot of people I don't
think anybody's off the hook when it
comes to like strange unconscious and
also unbridled rage self-loathing
confusion fear disgust jealousy uh
disloyalty like people that just like
think everything is attacking them so
they have to attack it that's happening
in that happiest like I'm not trying to
put Mr Rogers down I love Mr Rogers I'm
saying like he dealt with that too yeah
like there's no exception yeah being in
these bodies living in this earth means
sometimes you look at somebody and you
just go [__] this guy for no reason or
or he's gonna kill me for no real like
fear jealousy anger so we we medicated
in different ways and the reason I love
talking about this is it's nice to know
we're not alone yeah and there are
healthy there are healthier ways I'm
gonna say it is better to go for a walk
oh it is to get [__] up and get [__]
up yeah and it's also they might have
the same effect on your brain like
literally yeah like a good walk can
sometimes be yeah it sounds so lame but
but like having a run yes that exactly
it does it it's just you know what it is
it's like what some people sometimes
they can't fight the self-loathing
that's right you know because because
you need to love yourself a little bit
to do that to do that stuff you know
I've said it a million times and I don't
have a bottle of jogging in my freezer I
had a bottle of vodka yeah it was easier
it was easier you know because it
reaffirms if you think you're like you
don't go I'm a piece of [__] so
therefore I'm doing piece of [__] stuff
wasn't the show originally called punk
cast [__] yeah I was originally thought
that your website still says podcast oh
we've been meaning to take that off I'm
awful with my website and I don't think
anybody cares or it's only old people
like me that's like let's check out his
URL oh I I care about other people's
website but I'm just bad at doing my own
that's how I found out yeah I I actually
like this fool oh same here
punk ass [__] would have been a
gimmicky like name yes and it's not a
gimmicky show yeah it's not a gimmicky
show yeah and the and the only thing
that was the title just came from a joke
that I wrote several years ago this fool
yeah the the title punk ass [__] yeah
it came from and then I just told the
guys that I created the show with like I
don't think we should name it that oh
that's great great I thought maybe
somebody pulled reigned you in no they
said I we should I don't go I don't
think we should name it that because it
wouldn't dimensionalizes the show
this fool to me sounds like
I don't know like an invitation to
understanding a different terminology
yeah like white people don't use fool as
much as the Latino yeah that's right so
I was like oh cool I kind of get it yeah
it kind of works in both ways like
there's a literal food fool to it right
so the show and a bit of like just
saying like how Latinos usually say fool
a lot you know so yeah there was a
little bit of that and I just once we
had an artist do the title R which is
awesome oh thank you very very cool yeah
I just said oh there's an Elegance to it
that I think it's nice I gotta say it
again man just because it's just so rare
to watch a show where you're like this
show wanted to be oh like what I mean
you know what I mean like so many people
make a show because they were offered a
show yeah this seems like oh this needed
to be there's nothing like it oh there's
no story like this there's no there's no
vibe or flavor it wasn't derivative I
couldn't predict it and it's an
incredible incredible pilot thank you
one of the best openings of a show I
won't ruin it but the driving yeah the
driveway thing look I hate this I don't
hate it about myself but we all go into
new shows going like let's see what we
got you know what I mean yeah you can't
shut it off yeah of course but I'm like
obviously especially when you create you
know oh yeah oh yeah I'm gonna be like
this guy thinks he can make it I'm not
saying that's how I consciously think
somewhere back there and when you did
the thing with the car I was like
you're almost mad it's so good yeah and
Val Val was sitting next to me and she
was like that's the funniest opening to
a shot oh thanks man it's just nice to
see you can feel your drive and your and
your
desire to make it yeah not just like oh
I can make a show this show let's make
this show yeah I think when I met with
the guy I co-created the show with some
comedians
um Jake Weissman Madison britson and Pat
Bishop they used to have a show in
comedy Center called corporate and then
when there was an underrated show yeah
really underrated show and then when
they hit me up to do it
you know I kind of had no thoughts of I
had some ideas but so they approached
you yeah they approached me and they
said they just knew you from Comedy they
knew me from stand up they knew me from
the story I love this yeah they knew me
and I was like you know I was you know
how it is Stand-Up doesn't pay until it
pays so for a long time you just have a
job yeah it's like skateboarding yeah
they're really bad at it or suddenly
you're amazing yeah yeah and I was
working at my warehouse job when they
hit me up yeah and then doing stand up
at night and on the road on the weekends
and stuff and then they hit me up and
they were like we were like producing
stuff now which you want to work on
something with us and I love this yeah
what I want comedians to be doing with
each other yeah I never hear stories
like this yeah they were all cool
running around trying to get something
for themselves but they approached it
yeah because they already had their show
on Comedy Central and they said we're
like looking to produce stuff and make
other stuff and then I said yeah they
hit me up I remember was like I was
working literally unloading a truck and
then I said yeah let's meet up or
whatever and then
they told me they go we're kind of
thinking of something in regards to
where you live that part of South
Central South Central Los Angeles and
what you kind of talk about in your
stand up a little bit tonally and I said
all right cool and then I kind of came
up with and then we started crafting it
together I came up with the general idea
yeah of a guy who works at a gang
rehabilitation program and then because
I had I had family members that were
gang members and had been the president
yeah my real cousin uh was that drug not
that it matters if it was drugs yeah it
was directly a few of my cousins okay a
few of my cousins who had been in prison
who had been in gangs which is kind of
addressed in the show yeah which is the
like the corporate the money what is it
it's uh what Mike Michael Imperioli said
oh the non-profit it's like you guys are
victims yeah your victims which is yeah
true it's like there's this insane like
there is an industrial complex yeah to
make money and it's like okay so we need
to fill this yeah you get the people and
you get them in yeah it's a cycle
absolutely and um
we started crafting it from there and
they said oh we like this but we don't
want to make it just a workplace like
what's this guy's home life like yeah
and what are his relationships like and
we started kind of modeling after
themes that I had in my head and one of
them was like codependency
and then I just I've always been
intrigued by the idea of like
codependency after I found out what it
was I kind of found out in the funniest
way I had a I got done with a
relationship this woman had broken up
with me and I was telling my my friend
foreign
telling her what happened and she said
she sounds like she's codependent so I
said what's that and she kind of
describes it to me so I bought a book on
codependency codependent no more no
women who love too much
and then I always joke around that I
found out I was a woman who loves too
much because when I read the book I said
I think this is me yes because I the
only reason I bought that book was to
say I'm gonna learn what codependency is
so I can help her ass out yeah not be
codependent no more yes and then then I
thought the fact that I'm doing after
reading that book I said I think the
fact that I'm trying to help her is
codependency yes because my life wasn't
like shambles you know right so also
what I liked was also just it's the idea
of like um
what is altruism you know like you're
kind of you don't you don't know some
people are altruistic but some people
are kind of helping others a lot of
codependencies to kind of help help
others to forget your own problems and
then pat yourself in the back about it
that's right so you can tell yourself
you're a good guy because you don't
believe yourself to be a good guy
to other people and yeah I'm gonna fix
you yes when it's like wait
yeah I'm only I'm not really seeing what
I don't like about myself and yeah yeah
I've said this before on the Pod but
it's this is 100 out of life I I was in
a codependent relationship
and I said to her I was like I just
found out what it was how old are you
man I was like 27. okay because I didn't
find out what it was until I was like 32
31 maybe and I said to her I was like we
we should read codependent no more and
she went let's read it together and she
wasn't she wasn't kidding oh my gosh she
wasn't getting and that's when I but
it's one of those things like
how many people like Valen I know that's
my wife we have codependent Tendencies
like yeah and I know that too yeah it's
just like it's happening yeah but we're
kind of like we go like as long as it's
working for us like you know what I mean
like we're also having an awareness is
good it's not having an awareness of it
right you know right yeah yeah because
you can regulate something if you have
an awareness of it what is what like I'm
actually asking in case you remember
better than me that's not saying I'm not
embarrassed that I can't Define it
exactly but it's it's nebulous it's like
it's like needing yeah needing to help
others in order to forget your in order
to avoid your own problems okay that's
interesting did you know uh father Greg
Boyle did this podcast from multiple
Industries yeah that's one of the best
episodes yeah and one of the things I
love about him is that he'll tell you
that he's in homeboy to help himself
like he's doing it not not at a
codependency but he's like I'm not
trying to save anybody I I'm saved when
I work with them like through the
process of it yeah but it is interesting
and I thought the show does a great job
of making fun of the idea that it's like
the cupcakes or like who's helping who
that sort of stuff because that is how
most people are father Greg is yeah is
just a living yeah yeah absolutely but
when I help people what is altruism and
what is codependency and how much do I
just I can't bear the thought that I am
not useful yeah or think of others but
that's just because of me yeah and it's
just one of those things it's like
sometimes
yeah I find myself in these situations
where like even with my family I they
would ask me to help them with something
and families are codependent yeah and I
would go I would say with an attitude
all right I'll [__] do it and then my
mom would say well don't help me with
that face and I go no no I want to help
and then like so it's like one of those
things where it's like it was just funny
to help
in a way that's like I just wanted to
say that I did it you know of course
like because your identity when it comes
to family yeah it hinges on like good
son bad son yeah close family not close
family some of those things are too
painful to deal with yeah and for me
I often do stuff like let's say my dad
will ask me to call his friends friends
son who wants to get into comedy yeah
and I'll say to Val I'm like I know
there's there is a route I I tree graph
it I go I could go Dad I really wish you
would ask me like do you mind reaching
like you just tell me to do it I don't
feel like you see me as a grown-up I
don't think I don't feel respect or
whatever it might be however I want to
articulate that but when I plan it out
I'm like okay it's a three-month no
or a 30-second yes and I just go sure
Dad and I call this guy and then I have
a laugh with him because he didn't want
his dad to put him like neither of us
wanted it to happen sometimes you
actually make a friend out of it but
like nothing was gained learned or
achieved like my dad doesn't have any
better understanding of me or my
feelings yeah so it's like a temporary
fix but I'll pick that temporary fix
rather than the because you know why
dude I don't think at the end of that
three months that it's even possible
that my dad would go like you know I
never even thought that you might have
felt that way yes he'd just be like oh
Big Shots
it would be three months of that yeah
and then would end in the same spot or I
can just go [__] man okay and I'm not
proud of that yeah but it's also a lot
of that I think probably has to do with
accepting who your father is I love that
yeah yes me forgiving that yeah and
surrendering like yeah yeah I think it's
like it's just accepting you know I
think it'd be different if you were
going out of your way to help this
person in a way for you to or to like
kind of pat yourself in the back about
it you're right yeah I want to just get
it over with yeah you just kind of want
to get it over with and you know you'll
do a solid for your dad and his friend
right you know as opposed to like let me
take this young person under my wings
and stay on top and then stay on top so
my dad will go like Well Done Mike well
yeah yeah so yeah we were just trying to
get in themes of like codependency oh
thanks man and then also just looking at
things through like a working class lens
you know like the fact that these people
live in South Central Los Angeles and
kind of trying to depict the LA that
like
is in like the rest of La literally the
flyover party yeah yeah it's literally
yeah you fly over South Central and
Inglewood you fly over Compton South
Central and the wood that's it Atlanta
next into the airport that's how you
know you're almost home yeah and then
you can drive around yeah you get home
yeah which is funny yeah I've lived in
La uh for you know I was here for 10
years or so
never made it to South Central like
maybe once to the Compton exit yeah
because there's something over there and
I was like is this am I supposed to do
that like I still think of it as the
thing dissuade me of that or tell me oh
yeah you know you know what I love about
it is also just growing up down there in
that part of La is that like I remember
a few years ago when people in doing
comedy and like being around this part
of town which is like Los Feliz or
Hollywood or East Hollywood or whatever
people talking about like you know
people who are in the Arts will you live
in the area and like I remember doing
comedy out here and there was a
discussion years ago about Ladybird I I
don't remember what the discussion was
which was a good film yeah but I just
remember it was getting to be a
discussion that was like what's the
point of this and I just thought you
know what what I like about where I live
the point of the movie ladybird no
what's the point of all this discussing
it and I thought you know it's great
nobody's talking about Ladybird where I
live and I go and that's not to say that
they don't watch ladybird or have an
appreciation for like independent film
that's great but they got better [__] to
think about you know you have done it
that is so funny yeah they might be
watching Lady Bird but it's not lighting
up the corners yeah
you know it's like yeah that's what it
is it's like that's not to say there's
not somebody down there who watches
Independent films yeah yeah because
there is you know but yeah but you know
I grew up down there and what I liked
about down there it's like it
metaphorically feels 200 miles away
people have real jobs like you know my
mom's a janitor it's not like just
Showbiz yeah it's not show busy and
those aspects that feel so busy are
people who like dudes who want to rap or
people who went to become athletes right
which is the same for Chicago yeah yeah
it doesn't it's not unique it's not you
it's the one thing that I think is
unifying is that like every city has a
working class population or a working
class section you know and that's the
one thing that like you know I think
class can be a unifying thing especially
if you're working class and like you
know what it's like whether you're white
black Latino or Asian or Native American
if if you don't have money to fix your
roof you know that putting a blue tarp a
tarp over it will stop it from leaking
right you know that's right it's a
Band-Aid that's right so and that's a
language it's a language yeah I think
it's a language or recycling you don't
recycle for the grade of the better of
the earth it's you take your recycling
down because you know you're gonna get
like 30 bucks for it yeah right you know
yes so I think I just like I think
recycling in the way you your attitude
towards it says everything about your
class yeah because yeah I've said this
before in the Pod too but like the very
very rich people I know are like
obsessed with recycling yeah and doing
it properly yeah because it's one of the
few things it's one of the few like
conflicts yeah that remain like can you
recycle a pizza box yeah cheese in it
yeah it's like you know what man we're
talking about Ladybird right now
yeah this isn't like a real conversation
yeah so yeah just kind of instilling
those things but yeah living down there
it's always been
I don't know it's uh it has its own
things you know like its own problems
but it also
I I don't know I think what I liked
about it especially once I started doing
more and more comedy is that it grounded
me in the sense that people didn't care
that I did comedy down there yeah you
know or like they have their own things
or even like thinking about my mom like
you know she she didn't speak much
English and she never so if she went to
go see me stand up she probably wouldn't
understand most of what I'm saying oh
well you know so there's that those are
those aspects to it that I kind of like
that I'm like that's freeing that's
grounding it's more grounding you know
they don't give a [__] or I or sometimes
when I hang out with my friends who
still live down there is that you know
they either work in construction or they
have office jobs or you know maybe they
are a teacher or something but they
sometimes they'll be interested as much
as they're probably interested in
selling telling me me telling them about
what I do they're also interested in
telling me what they do right or talking
about their kids right which is kind of
nice because you just go you know you
want to forget you know that's what Rob
Riggle said to me when we had our baby
goes just remember nobody gives a [__]
about your kids and that's La yeah
that's not the rest of the world yeah
when I visit my friends in Ohio yeah
yeah they want to hear about your kids
yeah la doesn't give a [__] about your
kids because they can't make any money
yeah so like with my friends who live in
that other part of La it's like they
care you know or they want to hear that
kind of stuff and okay again I'm gonna
risk being embarrassed because there's
just certain feeling just tell me if I'm
way off the mark But was is there more
Community is there more of a sense of
like
this is our neighborhood this is our
a little bit I mean or no yes and no I
think yes in the sense that like when
[__] goes down people feel probably
attached to their neighbors or people
you know so sometimes you get
multi-generational housing where it's
like you know you get this kind of like
where
the kids live there with their
grandparents and their kids and you know
so you're seeing people kind of growing
up with each other so really I think
there is that sense of like right
Community you know so but also down
there sometimes there's like racial
tension you know sometimes there's like
sometimes there's tension between
Latinos and blacks sometimes there's not
like sometimes we're the best of friends
sometimes we're not like it's all it's
not one thing yeah it's all Ebbs and
flows you know right and it's all like
you so there's things like of that
nature I think I just I think where I'm
basing that on other than movies
obviously is is like again I read the
book tribe please put in the sound of a
round of applause here just kidding what
are you talking about I know Mexico is a
different situation yeah but you'll see
the parallel Mexican people that
immigrate uh to the United States and
make more money often more suicide more
depression yeah and it's it's because
like
the forced Community here's another way
to speak to it in my life when I was in
college and I lived in the dorms I was
just like kind of happier not that not
that I am now because it turns out I
like being alone a lot but like that
forced Community time in my life was bad
at times but then it was also good in
these other ways that's what I mean it
kind of emphasis and flows you know or
sometimes there's like
you guys are angry about you know
there's tension or there's not and yeah
yeah I think it's not well but I think
people talk to each other more yeah
maybe it what to let themselves know
that they're either pissed off or or
happy interesting yeah interesting I saw
in your stand-up you talked about being
in a lot of fights is that true you lost
a lot of fights yes and no in the sense
that in the sense that I talk about I've
been in a lot of fights but I lose those
fights yeah you know because there's
like an honor in that
like it would have just always crack me
up because sometimes I would see guys
fight and then a guy would the guy that
one would lift the other guy up and go
you know what I respect you because at
least you fought me and stuff like that
really yeah yeah what yeah it makes it
makes sense and no sense at the same
time oh no I get it both ways too I get
it I actually think it's kind of like
I don't know yeah I don't want to say
it's beautiful because it's not
beautiful but there's something sort of
you know what it is it's an outside
perspective it's like you the junk food
it's like at least you're noticing or
I'm being codependent with Val but at
least there's an outside perspective
yeah so they're fighting but at least
there's an outside perspective of like
what does this mean who are we what does
it say about yourself yeah yeah so were
you well I think what was the situation
where you jumped no I've always always
you know sometimes when you're just like
when you grow up in these neighborhoods
and there's gangs or there's kind of
like you don't want to be a mark so
sometimes you go I rather have you kick
my ass
I'd rather us fight and you kick match
and then just let this happen let what
happened like the stalking the chasing
yeah the the like punking me or the or
the like I remember one time I got
robbed like I was like 15 some like gang
members from the same High School robbed
me and I just remember being like no
like give me your money and I was like I
I go we're just gonna have to fight
because like I just remember being like
nah we're gonna get down because I'd
rather you whip my ass that me just
handed over because then that it never
ends yeah really yeah so there is that
part of it where you just I don't know
if it's like a fatalism or like it seems
Machiavellian genius yeah you're like we
can do this in one lump payment yeah or
you can harass me for 10 years yeah
we're just one of those things where
it's like you just get so angry that you
go I rather you whip my ass than you
just take it from me I rather like
us have to go through this whole thing
like you're not gonna get it that easy
and also aren't you kind of calling out
that they probably don't want to even
kick your like it takes yeah energy yeah
yeah and risk yeah risk of getting in
trouble risk of getting arrested risk of
getting hurt yeah and even just beating
somebody up yeah is gonna be painful
even if you're really winning yeah even
if you're not getting hit it still sucks
to punch so a wooden person yes yeah
like you're basically wood with a little
Tempur-Pedic foam on it so I think
there's a little bit of that of like
when I was younger like that now just
[__] if somebody robbed me I'd just be
like I take it I don't give a [__] you
know but I think when I was younger you
probably have I'm sure I had the sense
of like pride of like being like you
know what it was I remember
this is a really dumb valuable lesson
that I learned when I was young very
dumb but valuable one time I was talking
[__] to my cousin and I was like 13 at
the time and my cousin had just probably
been out of prison and
I was talking [__] to him and I don't
know where he punched me
and then I was like 12 or 13 and he was
a grown man and he like punched me not
he didn't knock me out but he dropped me
and I remember getting up and being like
you know angry crying why would you do
that and then he calmly sat me down and
said you weren't expecting that were you
and I said no why would you hit me we're
families and that he goes okay
see
I'm family
and look at what I did imagine what
somebody who is in family would do to
you yikes and then he said you shouldn't
talk [__] to someone
unless you're willing to it to go
somewhere
like because they might get you yeah
they might get you that person who
you're talking [__] to if you they might
be willing to punch you and you and you
just think you're frivolously talking
[__] right you know so it might come
back to you it might come back to you so
you know don't
talk [__] to don't berate someone right
you know because I wasn't like arguing
with him I was berating him right right
you know different I was calling them a
[__] I was calling them all these
things and it wasn't like I was having
an argument because you can argue with
mostly anyone yeah it was berating him
yeah I was literally talking [__] so
then he said look at what I did to you
and I'm your family member and I love
you like there you go now imagine what
somebody who doesn't love you would do
to you wow he goes don't talk [__] to
someone unless you're willing to take
into the other level it took me a like a
day to process that yeah I was like yeah
I guess I didn't tell him he was right
but I was like I guess yeah it's
probably two games
that's interesting what was I just gonna
say no not not that but the thing before
was who cares let's live in the tension
yeah
I I was interested in in more of the
neighborhood stuff was there a feeling
of like
is it is it is the language used I'm
going to get out of here is that part of
it or is it no because I lived there for
a pretty long time up until like a few
years I lived there up until like during
Co during the pandemic I moved in with
my girlfriend in like in Las Vegas and
it wasn't with the again I'm getting
this from movies it wasn't like I'm
getting out of South Central it's just
where your girlfriend is yeah I was just
like I'm just well my girlfriend lives
in Los Feliz I'm just gonna move here I
actually it was never that like I'm
getting out of here because
I just liked where I live I understood
that
like yeah sometimes there's troubles
yeah but that's okay that's what life is
that reminds me of what I was gonna say
yeah
when you were like you're gonna have to
fight me you're 15. yeah so they they
they're trying to rob you and you say
we're gonna have to fight would that end
it like you wouldn't be a punk at that
point yeah I mean it would probably
ended it it's like this guy's a pain in
the ass
it would just be like he's not an easy
right he's not an easy Mark like it's at
least 20 minutes yeah it's gonna take
some time they kind of like and it's
they want to Rob someone that will give
it to them right away because they're
scared and I was scared but I just at
the time was like I'd rather not like
we're just gonna
I'm not I don't want I'm gonna feel
worse if I just give it to you yes you
know for sure yeah which maybe in
hindsight it's probably just because I'm
young and I'm not in control of my
emotions like that now someone tried to
rob me just [__] take it I don't give
a [__] of course yeah no it's not worth
it I'm not I would never say just kick
my ass yeah or we're just gonna have to
fight her right I uh yeah in Father
Greg's books there's all these it was
always I guess the randomness of gang
violence is always the most I don't want
to call it it's the most terrifying
thing but it's one of the terrifying no
it's random it's Randomness especially
if you're not a gang member right
because so you know from my
understanding being or growing up with
some of those guys in my family were
being around some of those guys just
growing up in my neighborhood it's that
they understand
it's not random to them because it's a
life they leave they live yeah but it's
random to you if you're just walking
down the street and somebody robs you or
shoots you you know George says where
are you from where are you from and
stuff like but you're not from any which
means what gang are you in yeah and
you're not in a gang but they kind of
know you're not in again yeah it's just
it's like asking somebody like in the
30s got a light yeah really they just
want to kill you or what time is it yeah
or whatever it is and that always yeah
chills me yeah did you live in a in a
fear of gangs and that type of I think
I think if you're Street Smart you just
go oh I know where to go you live in
fear of like I don't want to get [__]
with but you just know you learn how to
talk to people too you know like oh you
know those are those guys and be cool
with them you know like right don't be
too Meek around them or no how
interesting so you have to kind of yeah
representative yeah yeah just don't be
too minkish or whatever but also
there is a sense of like
you're scared of them because they you
know they can do something and they will
do something most of the time but also
sometimes when you have family members
that come from that it just goes you
kind of know how to talk to them
you know so it's just one of those
things and or they feel familiar to you
enough or whatever so interesting yeah
but it is yeah it is interesting it's a
real dichotomy because I was just to say
like I underst
it's weird because if you have family
members who are gang members is they
represent two things to you is that I
know they can be scary to you but
they're also loving to me and that's
complicated because you know maybe my
family member went to prison for killing
someone which I know objectively makes
them a bad guy but also I've known him
to love me right you know well that's
interesting giving me good advice for
treat me well that's father Greg has a
really interesting perspective on that
where he's by the way we're all
different levels of mentally ill so when
I say mentally ill I don't mean we're
desperate might be another way to put it
yeah or I guess you could say misguided
he usually says mentally ill meaning
anybody that killed somebody that was an
act of mental unwellness yeah meaning
they weren't getting something that they
needed again I'm not trying I'm not
trying to be father Greg that just
helped me to understand of course
they're loving in in these ways and then
there's a deficit or some yeah other
thing going yeah or another thing going
on that yeah you just you know it's an
upbringing that made them that way or
personal trauma well that's what he said
it's always there's that scale there's
the 10 questions it's like were you
sexually abused were you neglected were
you drugs
and he's like every gang member he's
ever met is eight out of ten at least
yeah yeah absolutely which means it is
an illness meaning here's how you catch
this disease yeah and he's like there's
a byproduct of environment like a
resources those kind of things
absolutely yeah so when we say mental
I'm just trying to be really careful
with my words because when you say
mentally ill it's like oh like the Joker
it's like no not like the Joker like
like all of us like yeah like
codependency yeah or or depression or
this or that it can manifest in all
these different ways and that's what I
love about those books is it just makes
you go like oh my God he always has
people that join gangs are never running
uh to something they're always running
from something yeah that makes a lot of
sense I mean people I know who have been
like that yeah who have been part of
gangs or family members I know I had a
few when I got older and I understand
like the complexities of human emotions
you go ah all right I see that they were
running away from something right
they're not like
they're not tough dudes for the sake of
being told that's what he says too he
goes they're not looking to kill
somebody most of them are looking to get
killed like yeah that's deep down yeah
yeah there's a fatal there's something
it's us with food or drugs or addiction
it's a similar sort of Despair or uh I
remember one time one of my cousins was
going back to prison and then I said
aren't you sad he goes and he kind of
said
it'll be like yes but at the same time
I'll get to relax
interesting he goes like I've been
running too crazy out here I always got
to look after my back like right look
you know so he goes I'll be at peace for
a bit or something interesting and
imagine see that's running from
something yeah I was running from
something father Greg also told that
story he went to some cop seminar about
why like the psychology of a gang member
yeah and he there's a pamphlet and it
says why do people join gangs and you
open it and it says in big letters
excitement
and he goes I'd make a list of 150
reasons why people join a gang
excitement wouldn't be on the list
but that's what we think it's like yeah
oh they want to be Cowboys or they're
bored and it's like no man some
something's really yeah let them down
yeah sometimes let them down and it's
tough and yeah I don't want to make I'm
quoting I just don't want to sound like
I understand oh no no I'm trying to
understand yes and I think that's what
it is I mean I think with a lot of those
guys it's sort of that that's the one
thing we tried to do in the show which
was like
because I was like how do we gotta make
these characters feel the comedy doesn't
fall on them right if you know because
anything can be made a joke I just don't
think there's anything too comedic about
certain people's trauma unless it's your
own trauma and you're making a cathar
you're being cathartic about it which I
totally get right but like yeah just
finding a way like how do you make that
the human humanistic backdrop and then
the comedy is me and my cousin who butt
heads right yeah it's uh I think that's
well put and going into the show I was a
little nervous just for you as an
undertaking I was like how do you do
this yeah how do you not make it be like
oh he doesn't he's stupid yeah yeah he
doesn't understand your references yeah
he resorts to violence too quickly like
pretty sure that's not what's going on
yeah yeah and then it's just you kind of
they're both similar very similar people
who just have similar it's me with a
different zip code yeah yeah or a
different upbringing yeah yeah maybe so
I think it's like yeah just finding a
way to do that and then even with
certain characters like with even the
micro Imperioli characters he's a
Unitarian Minister which was a way to a
challenge was to not make him feel like
a white savior right and we thought make
him as flawed as everyone else in this
show yeah and I thought it the way you
introduced him was great yeah just make
him as flat as anyone else because I
wasn't interested in making a white
savior character because it feels so
demeaning or or even like somebody like
I think sometimes when people paint
white liberals on TV they either pen
paint them as condescending yeah or or
white saviors in a way that it's kind of
Pat in their backs their own backs sure
and I go what about this old school
lefties like that exists you know who
are like the Bernie Sanders elk right
you know who's to have an anger to them
right and then like I thought about
unitarians because my girlfriend grew up
a Unitarian and she told me about going
to Unitarian Church and there's old
school lefties that still had a
fierceness to them yeah yeah still had a
fierceness to them but also seemed
deeply flawed human beings in the way
that everybody is right yeah I think
once you're once you're giving
when your life gets that real yeah and
when you're talking to Father Somebody
Like Father they're just real about
everything yeah they're real about
everything they're living real life
because he's seen it all and he's seen
it at all he's lost people so he's not
trying to pretend to be like the
politest or the happiest or the sweetest
guy yeah who's a real guy he's a real
guy and I don't think he's waxing poetic
yeah you know it's really cool that but
yeah I just I don't know
I like working class people or I saw
this movie called killer of sheep years
ago that really influenced the show and
it was just about this kind of depressed
working class dude black dude and watts
and it was I just that idea of like you
never see any when you you
you never see entertainment when it
takes place in in like places like South
Central or those kind of neighborhood
somebody be existential yeah yeah so
wanting to capture some existentialism
to the main character yes you know yeah
and you also don't see somebody making
uh pour over coffee yeah like the first
shot of the show yeah but that was also
this weird not that it's your job to
invite white people to the experience
but it is your job to not it in however
you choose to do it to go like hey don't
forget there's different types of people
everywhere and that was a very quick way
to go yeah they're all the same they all
come from the same place and they're
right they're they're both valid that's
right both authentic to the place right
but it did make give me a bridge to you
I also love Yeah coffee yes okay let's
come back we'll talk a little bit more
about the show but also I want to know
how you got into comedy I also want to
know if you've ever died almost died
seen a ghost seen an alien the hardest
time you've laughed all that when we
come back and I also want to hear a
little bit more about those that drug
phase you said we just kind of glossed
past that but we'll be back in literally
two minutes uh after this
pardon the interruption weirdos this
wonderful episode is brought To Us by
our friend at mizzen in Maine no joke I
said I guess it's and mizen and Maine I
like to say
umizen in Maine are the clothing company
that I am most excited about it is so
hard to find clothes when I am Touring
that are comfortable enough to wear on
the plane that are wrinkle resistant all
of that stuff that are going to stay
looking good that are warm enough but
not too warm and also look fantastic on
the stage I really can't overstate this
I'm not just saying this I'm not reading
it off the monitor missing in Maine
makes the best dress shirts and some of
the best pants that I've ever owned but
specifically their dress shirts fit
fantastic they have amazing cuts and the
fabrics and the patterns and the style
are second to none I've completely done
an overhaul I absolutely absolutely love
them and the best part is I can fly in
the shirt because it's comfortable and I
can walk right on stage age and I feel
and look great so the old dress shirts
the rigid ones the bad ones they're
they're all they all went to Goodwill I
used to dread wearing a dress shirt to
do a show or to be on camera but not
anymore and that's that's really the
whole thing it feels great what's the
first thing you do when you go shopping
you feel the material and honestly it's
the material that was ruining dress
shirts for me until I found mizen in
Maine you're not gonna believe it it's
not just another dress shirt from
another company they've completely
revolutionized and reimagined the
material that you use I don't want to
say it's athletic but it's certainly got
something to it that's a little bit more
give a little bit uh more together it's
almost like the dress shirt of the
future but it looks like the dress
shirts of the past
it doesn't look like it's from the past
but it's as good as the ones from the
past but it Blends in a little bit of an
a huge Improvement on the material
because we've all been there you put on
a dress shirt and it makes you wish you
were wearing anything else and that's
why you've got to check out mizen and
Maine the inventors of the performance
that's what I mean by futuristic the
performance fabric dress shirt because
there's nothing worse than being
uncomfortable and missing in Maine
doesn't think you need to be that way
that's why they made the most
lightweight breathable and moisture
wicking dress shirt on Earth that's what
makes it perfect for me for travel
perfect for being on camera and perfect
for being on stage because if I'm gonna
sweat I want to stay comfortable they're
high performance dress shirts are warm
in the winter and cool in the summer
think of your clothing as a secret
weapon for any occasion that's what
their clothing is I'm confident if you
give Mason and Maine a try you will
never go back to Conventional men's
clothing again I certainly know that
it's true for me first hand they are
actually the best dress shirts I've ever
owned and I felt a fabric like this
never before in my life possibly the
best part they are machine washable that
means no more expensive trips to the dry
cleaners Plus for cold weather they've
got amazing flannels pants sweaters and
jackets made from the same Mason and
Main material that they've become famous
for so even if you aren't a dress shirt
guy they've got clothing you need to
feel to believe so no joke guys this is
the best fabric best new shirts that
I've encountered I'm so glad to be
working with these guys and if you give
them a try I promise you're gonna you're
making a big mistake if you don't wear
mizzen in Maine I have a bunch of
missing and Main shirts they've become
my go-to dress shirt and uh I think
you're absolutely gonna love it now I'm
just talking from the heart I'm talking
from the heart so if you want the best
cold weather clothing this holiday
season check out mizen and Maine right
now if you go to mizzen and Main and use
promo code weird you'll receive 25 bucks
off any regular price order of 130 or
more that's 25 off when you go to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d
m-a-i-n mizen
m-i-z-e-z-z-e-n and Andy main m a i
m.com and use promo code weird do your
wardrobe a favor and show your support
of this podcast also this
is sponsored by betterhelp we've all had
those times in our lives when we wish
life came with a user manual but
unfortunately it doesn't which is why
talk therapy is such a huge huge help in
my own life and I'm so glad that better
help online therapy is bringing us the
next best best thing to a user manual
for life it doesn't come with a manual
so when it's not working for you it is
totally normal to feel stuck navigating
any of life's challenges can make you
feel unsure whether it's a career change
a new relationship trying to get out of
a relationship looking for a
relationship or becoming a parent
therapists are trained to figure out the
cause of challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills which makes
therapy the closest thing to a guided
tour of the complex engine called you
and betterhelp has connected over three
million people with licensed therapists
it's convenient and accessible anywhere
100 percent online therapy talk therapy
has been such a huge huge game changer
for me in my life as I always say on the
show and in these spots
it's greater than the sum of its parts
you'd think talking to somebody would
just be talking to somebody but there's
a magic that happens when you're talking
to a licensed professional that knows
just how to nudge you and guide you and
get that conversation and those thoughts
rolling in the right direction can
absolutely transform your life it
certainly has transformed mine I would
not be the person I am today if I hadn't
had some incredible therapy so as the
world's largest therapy service better
help has matched three million people
professionally licensed embedded
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can always
easily switch to a new therapist anytime
it couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms
no traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
weirdo that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash weirdo alright
everybody enjoy the rest of the chat
with Chris Estrada
and we're back we're back
um okay let's do the drug thing first
what was that you said you got heavy
into drugs yeah just partying with my
friends like but the hard stuff yeah
like
there was a friend I there was friends I
used to do like math with and stuff like
that and like I think a lot of it at the
time I was just probably had a lot of
self-hatred and it was a lot of like
yeah let's let's do this so let's see
what happens but I never had a full I
don't ever want to paint it like I I had
a full-blown addiction yes I felt like I
had I dabbled in that stuff because I
just it was like binging on a weekend
and let's get [__] crazy
yeah I never got its claws in me because
I had friends who it got their claws in
them you know and that had a real
repercussion to their lives and in a way
I felt like at the time I thought maybe
I was being a tourist you know you felt
even at the time in hindsight now I can
feel like you know what what gave you
the so a tourist is somebody that has
you know you're you're going deep in the
cave but you have a belay on yeah yeah
like a rope on you what was your rope
like who was kind of because we're
talking about and relay dating about
some self-loathing some self-love issues
yeah that sort of stuff that again I
think we all have but what was anchoring
you at that time you know I don't know
maybe of fear probably a fear really
getting just good old-fashioned fear
yeah a good old-fashioned fear I was
more of a let's see what hap what
happens happens but like
more of a
I think
when you get into it you gradually go
into addiction that like that tunnel I
think seems scary to me me too yeah it's
funny how some of those dare campaigns
when I was a kid like worked because
yeah like I'll never do snuff because
they showed us all the videos of people
that had no faces and I was like oh I'll
never put tobacco in my face I really I
see people do it I'm like what are you
nuts like I really think it's super
intense well so when you smoked meth it
didn't like light you up in a way that
you were like this like just that no you
know it's funny it made me go it made me
think of the things that I did when I go
it made me feel more comfortable and
like I'm a piece of [__] therefore I'm
doing this piece of [__] thing oh
interesting as opposed to this is making
me feel amazing it reinforces it
reinforced things I think I would often
do that I would do things that would
reinforce what I felt so you had to
start with the problem yeah which is the
belief that you were a piece of [__] yes
did where did that come from what was
going on in your family you know just
always self-doubt you know just like
whatever I had been through in my family
whatever struggles I had I think I was
just kind of like
you know low self-esteem which all
things that I think never leave you but
you learn how to cope with or you learn
how to fight yeah so I think it was a
lot of that kind of stuff you know did
your parents split up oh yeah my parents
weren't they weren't together and then
um I think it was probably that I was
always looking for like a father figure
to like I would try to look for it in
books and movies John Taffer yeah Dad
yeah yeah and then I see you on the show
you have a fake bar yeah just to meet
him you're like yeah this bar isn't
working yeah Chris can I see the permits
it's like just yell at me yeah yeah I
mean
but I think I think it was stuff like
that that raised by your mom more yeah
yeah raised by my mom my grandma stuff
like that you know but I also I think
it's just also probably just
what I think is probably
clinical depression yeah you know yeah
stuff like that always always was I
telling my friend the other day I said
it's hard when you have to you spend
your whole life thinking you're you're
sad because and you think well I must be
a poet
yeah that sees the world differently
yeah and then you just find out ah
something's actually just wrong with you
yes yeah it's not that you're a poet
your brain makes the wrong cocktail yeah
a little too much of this not enough of
that not enough of that yeah and did
that draw you to Comedy like when did
comedy come into your life I think
movies and comedy always came into my
life and as a as a way to just like you
know latchkey kid my mom would let me
rent movies all the time or I'd be at
the library so I think just even like
Arts like whether it was like punk rock
music or films and TV I think the first
comedy I really enjoyed was probably
like you know staying up to watch Conan
or Saturday Night Live or like you know
or whatever like
Mexican comedies that I knew about or
whatever and then
but I I didn't start stand up until I
was like
I started at 29. really yeah I'm 38 and
I started at 29. wow and it was just I
wonder if there's an advantage to that
though you kind of came in a little bit
more formed as a person probably I think
you know what it was too it was also
like
I started late because I think for a
long time I just was scared of taking
that leap you know and I think sometimes
with being so much into art it's
you start vicariously living through
other people
interesting you know what I mean yeah as
a fan it's one of the reasons I'm a
terrible fan yeah like that's why I sit
down to your show to be like let's see
what this piece of [__] has again
unconsciousness no but that's but I'm
not great at museums yeah great and
audiences but that's the thing is
sometimes I think even with like that
punk stuff I would go I love the
philosophy so much of I became more of a
fan of the philosophy of DIY it's gonna
say DIY and you it doesn't matter if
you're not good just start and you'll
get good yeah like I was probably more
of a fan than I was a practitioner of it
yeah yeah and I think a lot of that had
to do with like low self-esteem and I
remember one time telling a girlfriend
that I wanted to try stand up and she
said that's for losers and I went you're
right
oh my God that makes a lot of sense and
then I didn't do stand up for like but
she was she's not wrong it's for people
who have lost yes it is for people when
I when I started stand up I had just
been fired from a job yes yeah yeah so
and I didn't stand up after my first
wife left me it's like it is for losers
yeah absolutely right yeah thank God
there's something for us losers I just
at the at that point I didn't want to be
a loser to her yes you know but turns
out you actually did want to be a loser
yeah because that is the risk we're back
to what we were saying about stand up at
the beginning like making little origami
shakes out of your feelings is very I
you know I don't want to say frou-frou
or whatever the word is but it's similar
to painting a landscape yeah but we want
it to look like rock and roll it's not
yeah it can be both I guess I think it
was you know yeah just getting through
all that like getting to stuff like that
I became such a fan but what was good I
think it it informed me you know I I
like stand up much way before I ever
started it who did you like
um Colin Quinn I was a big fan of Greg
Geraldo oh wow you know Maria Bamford
David tell uh stuff like that that I
would listen to that I was like this is
great but also at the same time I liked
movies and I was familiar with people
who wrote movies and but it also seemed
like so impenetrable to me that I was
like well I don't know I'm just a
working class guy from this neighbor I I
don't know how you do it but I think
what was great about starting stand up
is that stand up is not impenetrable
they're literally an open mic yeah it's
open the first word is open yeah the
second word is the thing you hold that's
absolutely yeah even the name kind of
tells you what to do that's exactly yeah
get the mic so I think a lot of that was
that and then but yeah I think getting
into you know comedy and and film and TV
and stuff where did you perform first
if I remember correctly one of my first
open mics was that this it was it's no
longer around or the building still
there was a club in in South Central in
lemur park it was called Maverick Flats
okay it was a mostly like a black comedy
club night that they would have there
and I lived close by so I just said I'm
gonna go do it and then I did it it was
it was a comedy I'll stand up yeah they
used to have this like uh I think I went
the night they used to do almost like
Apollo style is that they would slam
their keys on the table or ring their
keys and once they wanted you off oh
yeah so I did that and then I think that
might have been my first one oh no
oh no never give the audience a
mechanism with which to unify the I know
tell you you're done yeah they give you
the life yeah I got the keys I gotta go
I'm getting the Kindle their keys the
jingle is like I kind of want you to go
banging them is like really you gotta go
yeah and was there like a
a pressure to do more like Bolder stand
up like because you watch the Apollo you
kind of attack the stage or at least
attack with your personality like go big
or or go confidently at least I think it
was for me probably to go confidently
and also go
colloquial you know I go well I live
here and I bet if I can write jokes
about where I live
they're located here yeah so that'll hit
you know I think I did I did okay enough
to go I should do this again you didn't
get the keys I got the keys like three
minutes in three minutes pre-key is
pretty good yeah so it's not bad you
know and then but yeah you wrapped it up
you're looking at your set list and if I
get the keys here that'll be my closure
but if I keep going I kind of hope I get
the keys before this bit because I don't
really have an end yeah but you know
stuff like that but I like you said I
mean it's for loser I remember like
wanting to start before like remember I
used to I was telling someone the other
day that I'm bad at like picking up
signs like you know when people
like I was remember I was talking to
this young woman she was she's an actor
and she told me one time she came out
and she just got like quit her job and
then she saw like she was in New York
and she saw like this
matchbook for acting school or something
she knew that's the sign that I have to
[__] that I have to go I go no good good
for you because I was always bad at like
picking up like I used to work at an
animal hospital uh and the dog went
stand up and I was like I don't think so
I don't think so but my job was to work
outside and
um
look over the parking the the parking
spaces and to pick up dog [__] and I
remember one time my finger poked
through the bag and went into the dock
[__] and then I instead of taking that
as a sign that I should quit this job I
remember saying like like I remember
crying like going up to the roof and
just being like what am I doing with my
life because I was like 25 or 26 at the
time and then being like what am I doing
with my life I like I had dog [__] in my
finger this and that and then I go this
is I'm never gonna do this again and
then I went back the next day and I
worked there for like another seven
months and I'm like I just knew I'm like
bad epic and I wish that was the moment
that I started stand up
oh my God and it's too late yeah you've
told the story yeah you can't go back
and be like and that's when I did my
first open mic and I went that night now
I just seven months I think I worked it
for like seven more months dude it's
also kind it's it's in the same ballpark
as codependency because I remember
having a girlfriend at the same
girlfriend and being like I gotta break
up with this person I forget she did
something that was very mean or
something like that that I perceived do
you mean I went in the shower which was
the only place I was ever alone uh
because we were always together together
so I took like an involve like a
unnecessary shower just to kind of think
it through yeah I was like I think
that's it like it was a bridge too far
we got to break up it was seven months
later seven months later but little did
she know she was dating someone who's
waiting any minute having them now seven
like vacations together I don't mean
like big trips of course
like with someone who was like I made up
my mind seven months ago yeah that's
like I say it anytime it comes up you if
anyone's listening and they're doing
that that's meaner than just breaking up
oh yeah like you learn that yeah totally
it took me a while Emily Gordon I think
was the one that was like that's you're
a bit about open relationships that's
like serial killer stuff here a bit but
also like just knowing you're gonna be a
couple of people being like but I'm kind
of bored yeah just kind of like stick
around just deal with your feelings
exactly yeah just deal with your
feelings it wasn't even bored I was
terrified of breaking up with her that
was more the issue like I knew she would
and she didn't it took 10 tries well
sometimes I would make a situ I would be
in those relationships where I didn't
want to be the bad guy so I would make
things not work so they would break up
with me yeah there you go yeah and then
be like good I'm not yeah I'm not a
breakup person I got dumped yeah I
listen to Radiohead yeah yeah exactly
that's for me yeah um all right well
that's that's comedy I love the keys
thing have you ever almost died
yeah I feel like I have
um well
when I was 17 I think 17 or 18 me and my
friends got shot at no yeah got shot out
in my neighborhood where my mom right
where I was living at the time in
Inglewood and there was we were coming
back from the beach and this guy was
like trailing us like once we were back
in my neighborhood and everybody we
dropped my friend off and this guy just
came out of his car and started shooting
at us and I think he was like high or
something like he must have mistaken us
for someone you know like
and
it was happening randomly but I felt
like with an intent that I go I he
thinks we're someone else right you know
right and then how old were you 17 17 or
18 yeah that was 17 or 18. and then you
don't want to run from gunfire and
flip-flops
sand yeah and then we just like hopped
back in the car and then took off but he
shot out one of my friends back windows
and then so that was one of the few
times I came close to that and then you
know in movies the back window always
just shatters and it's like oh glad
that's done but that means the bullet's
in the car yeah they didn't just hit the
window no like I just caught myself
being like well thank God I hit that
window yeah we went in the car like we
could have got you guys that's
terrifying and then
that happened I think you know a lot of
the things that I felt like I didn't
think about it but now in hindsight I
can tell well I almost died like one
time I was at the I was at a gas station
I went to go pump gas for my mom and I
got held up at the gas station I was
able to talk myself out of it what do
you mean like just the person yeah well
the guy he he held me up and then he had
a gun pointed at me and then he said
give me your money and then I gave him
what I had in my in my wallet which was
eight dollars but in my pockets I had 50
bucks and then the old pocket one yeah
and then he would suck I had 7 500 on he
asked me for his for my wallet and I
said how are you gonna take my wallet
and I had a picture of the uh Virgen de
Guadalupe the Virgin the Mexican Virgin
Mary and I showed it to him I said I'm
gonna take this I know like and then
like what did he say and then he I he
looked at me and he he just went he
smacked my hand and he said man [__] you
and then he got in his car and then
but what I thought was I go you know
I know that was a loaded pistol like he
could have in hindsight I'd go yeah
totally from the Virgin Mary yeah I
should have just given it to him you
know what it was though that wallet the
stuff that was in that wallet my Grandma
had given to me and she had recently
passed yeah so I was just kind of like I
don't want to do part with this you're
making me realize I've always thought I
have like a clip wallet that if somebody
robbed me I would try to remove the
money yeah like in like a David
Copperfield because I just don't want to
replace all this yeah what are you gonna
do with my idea yeah yeah what man I
think he did just it's quicker you know
give me your watch that's where your
debt and credit card is or whatever
right yeah so I feel that that's I can't
believe you had the wherewithal to be
like come on man it's my wallet I think
I was so like in the my Grandma had just
passed so the minute there was literally
like a virgin Mary little card photo she
put in there and now she gave it to you
she gave it to me so I was just like
this gonna give you my [__] wallet
you got my money
and you're not because that's a bold
thing to say after handing a thief I
mean I should have just given him the 50
bucks in my pocket you know if I wasn't
even thinking that right well the
adrenaline your heart had to be racing I
mean we can talk about it casually but
nobody with a gun pointed today is is uh
relaxing and then one time when I was 10
10 or 11 me and my friend this kid
Hector Soto we used to go to this comic
book store yeah you know Hector Soto it
was it was a comic book store on the
border between Inglewood and South
Central it was called the CBC the comic
book club this older like really sweet
older black nerd named Earl used to run
that color and
um
we were in there when it got robbed at
gunpoint and and the guy took money and
what was funny is he took a few comic
books too that were like on the wall I
don't think he like expensive ones yeah
he just correlated with those are
expensive valuable and valuable and then
I you know he pointed the gun at us and
everything
in hindsight you know I I know now that
like in everything goes by so quickly
but I know in those situations he skip
he's not scared he's scared yeah and I'm
not saying that that he he I'm not
justifying his actions because he's a
shitty person you're doing this yeah of
course yeah but you're keeping in mind
that he's still a person yeah he does
there's a great Bruce Eric Kaplan
cartoon he dressed for the New Yorker
and it's a guy robbing a couple and the
you know the bank the robber you know
the bank robber the thief has a thought
bubble and it says God these things are
always so awkward yeah and I'm like what
I like about that cartoon is
he's not suddenly a thief he's some guy
yes I mean Steve yeah who likes this
type of ice cream and and took how many
poops did he poop that day yeah when did
he go to sleep and like what's his
favorite movie and then he goes in it's
not like Central Casting he's a guy yeah
and his heart is jacked and he's scared
and he's working he could get hurt yeah
all that sort of stuff yeah you can get
her and then so as I got older I
understood like oh man he could have
people die that way by accident you know
by being scared yeah some you know about
what your cousin said yeah exactly yeah
exactly so those are the three that come
to mind I love that you're just like
those three times that I was at gunpoint
come to mind I'm like wow my my question
doesn't seem so cute anymore have you
ever almost almost bit it you're like
well three or four times I was shot at
okay
have you ever seen not just a ghost or a
UFO but anything that you can't explain
yeah I I feel like I have especially
like with my family being like like
Mexican Mexican people are superstitious
and then my grandma used to do these
um they're called limpiasas in in
Spanish but they're like literally when
somebody has like a like um
they're not feeling well they have bad
energy they call it or the iboi or
whatever like sometimes my grandma would
give a spiritual cleansings with eggs
like egg yolks or eggs eggs okay and
then crack the egg yolk and to like get
rid of it to get rid of it and maybe
it's a placebo and that you would feel
better afterwards yeah and stuff like
that that I like the intent is like
there's strong evidence for intent and
like and your thoughts yeah stuff like
that and then I remember
when my grandma died she she lived here
but she died in Mexico you know it's
really crazy I was really close to my
grandma and she
when she was going to a trip to Mexico
where she's from and like a week before
she left she we were talking and she
said I'm gonna go die there and I said
don't talk like that but I just thought
you're just being old and crazy you know
yeah and she goes no no I'm gonna go die
there it's it's fine she goes uh your
Earth calls your land calls you back
it's you know when your land is calling
you back and sure enough she went and
she died there and remember she said
make sure they bury me there like don't
bring me back here and then they buried
her there but I just remember her being
so sure of her like that she's gonna die
there your land calls you back yeah and
you always said your land calls you back
so there was there was something so like
um Mystic about that to me and he's like
and we buried her here in South Central
yeah yeah she married at the England
Cemetery
zero yeah your land calls you back yeah
but these plot prices are left I was
like I'm not gonna fly but fly it once a
year to give you no no I'm gonna drive
to the Inglewood Cemetery
let's keep this simple please it's more
expensive to take you back to the US but
it'll pay in the Long Haul because I
don't want to pay for flight to Mexico
once a year yes your grandson flies you
back yeah so we uh so stuff like that is
beautiful though and then
I feel like I don't know I feel like I
believe in ghosts in the sense that like
in terms of an energy and like where you
go this place feels Eerie or sure things
of that any connection to your
grandmother since she passed any sort of
feeling
this is usually where the lights flicker
no yeah
um
whoa there he is it took you that long
to start stand up
he doesn't believe it yeah seven mamas
yeah
um I would say
I've had few dreams about her oh I don't
want to force it yeah
yeah I have bad dreams about her I think
soon after I had dreams about her but
isn't it weird that dreams are just
visions that were just like yeah but
they don't count because everybody has
yeah eight hours of dream Visions every
night it's like it's still an incredible
phenomenon yeah your brain is like
Conjuring up these images it is really
crazy the weirdest one I ever had which
was not a dream but this when my grandma
died there
[Music]
um
she used to tell me about the you could
hear like so there's the part of Mexico
they're from there a lot of battles with
you know native Mexicans and the Spanish
and you know or and stuff like that and
there used to be this thing or at some
point I guess a lot of Apaches
immigrated to this place where they're
from called Zacatecas so she said that
years ago she told me that you would
hear you could hear their war cries oh
wow you could hear their war cries
sometimes when I when she died there we
I went down there and then I was we were
staying at a uncle like her brother's
place and we're waiting the funeral and
everything and one night I heard
something and I woke up my mom and I was
like 20 at the time
and she said I said what is do you hear
that she goes go to sleep those are the
Apache war cries because they say
Apaches had immigrated there and so that
always stayed with me the fact that I I
don't even remember because I remember
asking my mom hey do you remember that
last night and she didn't so either it
was the dream
or it was reality and my mom just went
it had this you know so it would have
been ghosts right I mean yeah it's not
like there's reenactments yeah no it's
not yeah it's not reenactment I went
straight to like oh like Civil War
enactments and yeah they were doing it
in the middle of the night yeah it was
pretty normal I love that she's like oh
don't worry it just ghosts go back to
bed yeah that was her yeah I don't know
why but that is the most like Mexican
like the way you're saying Mexican
superstitions like relax it's just
ghosts yeah it's just so good which it
would have been very on point for my mom
too yeah because my mom always one time
I heard her like cussing and like I got
home and she said I'm like what she goes
I felt there was bad spirits around so
my mom too in order to like she scared
him off yeah she said you gotta scream
my mom's reaction to ghosts is anytime
you feel there's ghosts in your house
just yell at them and go you stupid
[__] we don't want you here get
out of here wow I'm exercising
it was really funny the way just to hear
her say like that's how you deal with
ghosts you know
it's not any romantic ritual where you
call her a priest no you no no holy
water just tap water and swear it yeah
and just yell at them and tell them that
you don't want them in your house yeah
it works yeah oh that's fantastic
um okay last oh we didn't talk about the
meaning of life is there any sort of
oh I forgot the meaning of life do you
have any framework any any religious or
spiritual bent you mentioned ghost
energy Spirit you know I grew up
Catholic and
even though I don't believe in that
stuff anymore I think Catholicism is so
much symbolism like it's a lot of
symbols and sayings and all that stuff
so
it gives me a comfort even though I
don't believe in that stuff it gives me
a comfort to see it I have a rosary
hanging from my rear view mirror okay
yeah they have a Virgin Mary air
freshener
so like fantastic so those kind of
things I
I don't even know I don't believe in
Catholicism or most I don't because I
don't believe in God in that traditional
like religious way anymore but the
images have meaning for you yeah I also
just think they remind me of people like
it reminds me of my grandma so it's nice
to keep those things around yeah you
know but but I just yeah I the imagery
and I guess that's what imagery is
supposed to do or those symbols are
supposed to do they're supposed to evoke
a feeling or sure something and even
even like behind your thinking mind I
guess we could just say unconsciously
the Virgin Mary is a reminder that life
can come from avoid meaning there's no
conception but here's life yeah and that
is also what the Big Bang Theory is is
that there was a void and then life came
in yeah and it's also what Santa Claus
is it's these gifts come from an unseen
things so we love symbols that say like
don't forget there's something that
doesn't make sense yeah but it is going
on behind behind the scenes yeah and we
don't even have to I just
intellectualized it but we don't even
have to intellectualize it you might
just love Christmas yeah you might just
love uh something that reminds you your
grandmother but you know
your grandmother was a miracle yeah and
so are you and anything that reminds you
of that stuff and Taps you in I think
now I just look at things like more of
like
I think
life is mysterious and and also like a
behind I guess it's a substitute forgot
but the idea of a life force sure you
know like I just go ah it's
the great life yeah the great life yeah
that's what I I said I found myself
Leela's of my daughter is of the age
where she'll say why why why and we were
talking about death she calls death
bones which I think is so funny she goes
oh then it becomes bones or we saw
that's so poetic it becomes bones she
also sometimes says are we here yet and
I'm like are we yeah
and also a bird unfortunately birds fly
into our Windows uh from time to time we
put bird seed on it and we we taunt them
from the other side of the glass just to
kill them I'm just kidding but they're
always dying so she sees birds uh dying
and she's like where's where what
happens to the bird she didn't say it in
those terms and I just caught myself
saying like it goes back into the great
life and I was like
yeah like I had to reduce it to
something that maybe Leela would
understand without making her too
irreverent of her own Survival yeah but
I was like you go back into the great so
when you West Coast hippies La people
California people get a bad rap for
talking about a life energy and I I can
understand that or yeah sandals and that
sort of thing or the force but it's like
I always like to share this point that
the god of the Bible which is the one
that most people or a lot of people in
this country yeah are here to believe
yeah I was gonna say [__] with but yeah
yeah
remember God says to Moses I am that I
am so he's talking about I am emness I
am being meaning I am the source of
being I'm a life force yeah so it's the
same same thing life force just sounds
more like the internet like electric one
time heard I saw the documentary on Joe
Strummer the singer of The Clash and he
had this great quote that always stays
with me he was at a concert and he took
a moment to say say this to the crowd
and he says
don't forget that we're all alive at the
same time we're all alive right now at
the same moment and isn't that amazing
yeah and I just go yeah that is like it
gives me a sense of like wow what a it's
uncomp it's I can comprehend it and not
at the same time absolutely yeah I
remember Emily Maya Mills did some
strong psychedelic at a party and I said
what did you do she she didn't realize I
think she didn't realize what it was and
she just kept looking at people and
going we're here we're here and yes like
that's what yeah
and honestly that to me is a the big
difference between a good day and a bad
day is did we remember to remember did
we remember that we're here and this
conversation that we're alive at the
same time yeah there'll be a time when
we won't be alive yeah yeah that's
exactly yeah I was sitting on the porch
waiting for you and I was just breathing
and I was like isn't it weird you know
like meaning mindfully breathing I was
like isn't it weird that like someday
another breath would be like the thing I
want the most yeah and I was like not
today though today it's just one million
one like of the day like it's really
something else to I guess be alive and
experience and being conscious and being
conscious and experienced yeah of it of
the complexities of human emotions that
you're gonna feel yes like you know
whether it's like happiness or sadness
loss or wins and like and and it's not a
lot of them aren't that binary yeah you
know that's right they're like a lot of
them aren't happy sad is a thing yeah
happy sad is a thing yeah you know or
like happy loneliness you know meant to
project unto you but uh this fool got
season two that's like happy and also
like
we gotta you know there's like an
OverWatch it's Dreadful yeah in a way
yeah you know it is like making another
season of TV that you've done before is
like wow I feel very lucky too and oh my
God I'm [__] terrified yeah it's a
lot of work I didn't intend on doing
this but
for me the second season of crashing was
really difficult because the first one
has all of this energy of like I can't
believe we're making the show yes in the
second season for me if you're not
conscious meaning every morning going
like we're live at the same time
the show is just an excuse to hang out
yeah with your friends with the writers
the actors with the crew
it's a it's a special opportunity and to
be grateful all of those things if you
don't do those things mindfully to me
the feeling was like we just did this
yeah like it's another season and and
more story now it can start to feel like
a grind you you lose your footing yeah
so I'm not saying that to you for any
reason other than you're in the unique I
have to stop myself from being that way
because I because I well wired the same
way yeah you often go this is now a
burden it's a blessed burden but it's a
burden and it it makes me feel bad
because in hindsight I go why didn't I
take more pictures like yeah you know or
like why didn't I do that but I guess I
I always look at things like
incremental wins or I incremental goals
yeah I don't look at like wow the fact
that I'm making this TV show is where I
want to be because I didn't I didn't
start to stand up comedy for those
reasons I just go wow this is a new goal
to take on and then whenever that is
done with move on to whatever the next
goal is you know yeah that's right yeah
but it is amazing you know and I but I
think I get so
you know you get so perfectionist about
things and you want to make well maybe
we should be talking about it because I
mean a lot of people are going to
project on to you a lot of happiness and
fulfillment that you may not be feeling
yeah yeah because you're like so what
Larry David quitting Seinfeld yeah I
just don't want I can't think of any
more stories yeah driving me crazy yeah
so you have to like give yourself
where everybody needs to give themselves
permission to feel how they're feeling
yeah but I would say what fixed it for
me in the third season was having a I
don't mean like necessarily it was a
spiritual practice but like just a
routine of going like just today just
these scenes yeah the Mantra it's just
an excuse to hang out yeah is like was
really powerful for me that's great
instead of thinking about the edit and
thinking about how it's going to be
received how it's going to be reviewed
is this story stupid it's just like man
this is an excuse to hang out yeah yeah
and have fun and create yeah yeah and
and not just how lucky are we but like
how lucky are we all yeah you know you
see somebody you know at a coffee shop
that's also as lucky luck is luck is
like good is good is good yeah so like
uh I guess I am just trying to encourage
you to be like feel how you feel and
don't
don't believe it when people are like
wow you're doing the second season man
projecting on TV how they think they
would feel yeah when in reality they
probably feel like how you feel which is
more than one emotion at the same time
yeah yeah and that's yeah I find things
are always that you know they're not a
binary or they're not just one thing
it's like it's they're both exciting
uh boring sad angry all at the same time
yeah [__] a yeah I love that
um well thank you Chris thanks for
having me there is one more question
yeah and then I ask you 50 000. just one
more
um can you think of a time in your life
you laughed really really hard and and
that's where we'll get out and I always
like to give these caveats it doesn't
have to be a great story yeah just like
maybe you're a kid maybe it was recently
with a friend maybe you were on drugs it
doesn't matter somebody fell down
somebody farted pooped their pants yeah
just if you were laughing at the point
of Tears who are you with how old are
you what happened jeez I'm trying to
think things that really makes me laugh
like that
you know sometimes
I
I [__] my pants in front of my
girlfriend like
like
about
God maybe a year ago like in front of
her yeah well we went out for a hike and
then I'm lactose intolerant and I have
like IBS yes and we went over in Topanga
Canyon and I had to go to the bathroom
there was nowhere to go so I didn't shed
my pants but I had to shut on the trail
and I felt such
yeah I felt so I felt so embarrassed
because I'm very self-conscious about
bathroom stuff like oh no we play I play
music when I go to the bathroom I don't
you know I'm very self-conscious about
that yeah I'll put my earbuds in so I
don't hear myself yeah yeah it's not
just for the other people I'm like I
don't want to hear me yeah so I do all
that and then I and it wasn't until a
day later I was just like
I just I wasn't even with my girlfriend
I was by myself and then I started
laughing about me and the point that I
started crying after the fact yeah after
the fact where I just went because I
felt such drat I went home I took a
shower I went to sleep I didn't want to
see her outfit yeah you went to sleep I
went to sleep you had to shut it down
yeah
I can't feel this so I think that I
think laughing at the Ridiculousness of
having to do that and I think my
girlfriend trying to be comforting to me
and the last thing he want is anyone to
talk to you after you have to do that
you know and I think she kept saying
like don't worry this is better we've
been together for six years it's better
that this happened now than the first
year six years
there's paper wood copper poop poop yeah
so I think like a day it was two days
after that I started just I was thinking
about it and it just made me laugh so
worse I mean if you try for a nature
wipe or did you just go natural dude I
didn't even think of that because I've
never been in that situation and we had
I had literally had one napkin left and
I used a napkin and it wasn't until
afterwards where I told my friend he
goes why didn't use one of your socks
one of your socks that's a man who's
pooped on a trail yeah and then I just
thought why didn't I use one of my socks
because yes there's no way I was clean
don't buy a brown sock
that's all we always said
I love that thank you for sharing that
story I also is there a better meaning
to coping with life [__] on a trail
you don't want your girlfriend even
comforting you get out of here you go
home and shut it down and then a few
days later or whatever it was you've had
time to process it yeah and those things
become the biggest laughs well what made
me laugh about it is I just kept
thinking I was like it made me laugh
because I go she has sex with me and
then I just go and I'm I'm like [__]
myself you know like it just made me
laugh where I just go I go that's so
disgusting like I just go so funny it
doesn't make me laugh because I go I
would never be with someone like that
not if that was your first date yeah but
six years she's right here she's yeah
six years I Val wouldn't mind me saying
we were coming back from the Vegas
airport and she was at morning sickness
and so she puked um outside of the Vegas
airport and while she was vomiting we
both like had a mind meld and we're like
everyone at this airport thinks she's
hungover because it's a Vegas Airport
yeah I'm like you want to scream like
she's pregnant yeah they're like well
she shouldn't be drinking like yeah
um Chris I I just had a feeling I would
like you um thanks I really enjoyed you
thank you you're super funny you're one
of a kind that's obviously that by
definition thank you and the show is
fantastic that really means the world I
haven't seen the whole season but we're
going to keep watching it thanks man
thank you yeah would you say keep it
crispy yeah keep it crispy there it is
yeah thanks man
man
oh yeah
[Music]